ده تغريده عمرها خمس سنوات حلقت في الفضاء
الرقمي ب 140 حرفا لكنها كلفت كثيرا كلفت
الملياردير الامريكي شهير الى الماسك 20
مليون دولار و20 مليون اخرى دفعتها شركه
سيارات الكهربائيه تسلا قال ماسك حينها
انه يفكر في تحويل تسلا الى شركه خاصه
يبلغ سعر السهم فيها 420 دولار ثم ختمها
بان التمويل لكن القصه لم تجري كما اشتهى
ماسك ففي البدايه ارتفعت اسهم تسلم بنسبه
11% مع اللحظات الاولى من نشر التغريده
لكنها لم تصل ابدا الى المستوى الذي وعد
به والبالغ 420 دولار للسهم وبلغت اعلى
مستوى لها في ذلك اليوم عند 387 دولارا
و46 سنه والسرعه امام انخفضت الاسعار
اسعار الاسهم الى ما دون سعر ما قبل نشر
التغريده البال اغتال 344$ حيث سجلت 236
دولار و24 سنه للسهم بعد شهر واصبح من
الواضح ان التمويل كان اقل من المامول مما
دفع المساهمين الى رفع دعوه وصلت الى
المحكمه في سان فرانسيسكو اليوم بدات
اجراءات المحاكمه عبر اختيار اعضاء هيئه
المحلفين الذين سيتعين عليهم تقرير ما اذا
كان ماسك قد كتب تغريد احتياليه عام 2018
كما يتهموه المستثمرون ام لا هكذا اعتدى
ماسك ان يكشف عن افكاره وربما عن الكثير
من سياساته بسيل تغريدات لكنه لم يكن يعلم
ان المستثمرين ما زالوا عالقين عند التلك
التغريده خاصه وان حكما سابقا قضى بان
تغريده 2018 شهيره يمكن اعتبارها كاذبه
ومضلله وحينها ترك ماسك للتناحي عن رئاسه
مجلس استسلمى وصل الامر الى حد مطالبه
الهيئه التي تشرف على البورصه المسبقه على
تغريداته المتعلقه بنشاط تسلا من محامي
متخصص
لايك ورده تسلم
حول سيارتي تسلا رائعه لانه بذل جهدا
كبيرا عدا ذلك اعتقد ان كل افكاره الاخرى
ضعيفه وهو يفعل ذلك فقط لكي يتحدث الناس
عنه يريد ان يلفت الانتباه اليه لذا ليست
كل افكاره ابداعيه الا في حاله تسلا
مبدعه انه رجل مبدع جدا لكن اظن انه رجل
خطير نوع لا اعرف لماذا لقد شعرت بذلك
لكنني اعتقد ان افكاره جيده جدا انه رجل
ذكي
هذا كل ما في الامر وانا اؤمن بذلك
كان في حاله ماسك وكنت قادرا على ان تكون
مثمرا وان تجني المال عليك ان تسال نفسك
هل كل هذا لي ام ان لدي مهمه لمساعده الاخ
وما المطلوب مني فعله بموهبه ليستفيد
الاخرون
الى المحاكم اما يخرج منها منتصرا او يجر
اذيال الخيبه بعد محاكمه ستستمر عده
اسابيع وابلغ القاضي ادورك هيئه المحلفين
المحتملين بان المدعيين يزعمون ان تغريدات
ماسك كانت خاطئه من حيث الوقائع واثرت
بشكل مصطنع على سعر سهم تسلا واسهم اخرى
وسبق للقاضي ان رفض نقل الاجراءات الى
ولايه تكساس الامريكيه حيث نقل ايلون ماسك
مقر شركه تسلا وجادل محامي ماسك بان
الملياردير لا يمكنه التمتع بمحاكمه
محايده في سامسونج فرانسيسكو حيث اشترى
تويتر في اواخر اكتوبر وتعرض الانتقادات
واسعه لقراراته من سياسه اداره محتوى
المنصه وصولا الى ما وصف بمجازر تسريح
الموظفين واكد المحامون بان الاعلام
المحلي اغرق في الاشهر الاخيره هذه
المنطقه بقصص متحيزه وسلبيه عن ماسك
كتهامه بخلق القانون والقاء اللوم عليه
شخصيا في تقليص عدد الوظائف لكن قصه ماسك
مع تسله لن تنتهي هنا فيبدو ان حلمه
لمشروع القياده الذاتيه يواجه عثرات عده
يبدو ان ماسك يقود تسلا او تقوده هي نحو
حائط وعلى الاغلب
المكابح لا تعمل